chase is with us in st louis uh good
afternoon chase how can christy and i
help
hey guys thanks for having me on the
show oh no problem at all man how can we
help bro
so i'm a i'm a second
semester junior so i'm just i'm about to
finish my junior year of college okay
um i just transferred to my four-year
university after attending community
college in the past
okay up until this up until this point
i've paid for all my tuition out of
pocket by myself awesome um
because my goal is just to graduate
debt-free
so i took that a subsidized student loan
of 5 500
my plan for the next two semesters of
college is to
pay the last two semesters out of pocket
like i did in the past
but i'm starting to rethink that idea
as federal student loan forgiveness is
kind of a discussion in politics
[Music]
do you guys think i should get two more
loans to cover the remainder of my
school or should i just
pay for as much as i can out of pocket
chase let me ask you this question man
you sound like a very bright smart
young man have you done any research
around these forgiveness programs
um not completely
okay let me let me help you out because
i want to make sure that you know
i want to give you an opinion i want to
give you facts okay
the facts are are showing that only one
percent of the people
who actually apply for the student loan
forgiveness program
um are getting approved so that's 99
of the people right now are not getting
approved
so let me ask you a question with
knowing that
fact right there as a young man in your
shoes do you want to rely
on them to forgive you
no exactly i probably should not
exactly who's the best person you can
rely on
definitely myself there you go there you
go young man
that's it right there here's the thing
um to answer the question uh directly
and i'm pretty sure christy will agree
with me no you should not rely on
someone else you should not rely on the
government you should not rely on the
white house
you should not rely on congress to take
care of your house bro
you've worked hard to stay out of debt
continue working hard
to stay out of debt continue working
hard to take control over
your life and i promise you when you
turn 30 years old when you turn
35 you have a wife you have kids you're
going to say thank you to your younger
self
because you put in the work and you
avoided debt at
all costs okay it's going to be hard i'm
not going to sit here and play with you
it's going to be hard
it's going to be frustrating there's
gonna be some days you feel like giving
in on these last two semesters
but when you walk across that stage
brother and i hope america you all are
listening to me
when you walk across that stage with a
debt-free degree
and when you get around your friends and
they're talking about the college
experience
and they're over here crying and whining
because they have fifty thousand a
hundred thousand dollars in student loan
debt and you're like i have nothing
you're going to feel like superman
you're gonna feel like man it was
worth it so do not give in to because of
the talks right now no stay true to your
path
stay true to who you are and graduate
100
debt free and our brother i'm telling
you right now you do that
you're setting yourself up to be a
millionaire here's the thing too chase
that's so
cool number one you've already done it
you're really really close
you've already done this you've already
cash flowed your college up to this
point which is incredible and unlike the
vast majority
of college students so you have this
skill you have the confidence you've
done it before
you know you can do it again and finish
this